tout de suite retrouvez l'actualité de
la semaine retour en images les
principaux événements du département
mardi 28 juin les élus du conseil
départemental se sont réunis en séance
plénière
les conseillers départementaux ont voté
la création de maaf maisonde
accueillants familiaux pour que le
grammont se sentent vraiment chez lui ce
sera une maison avec un jardin en coin
une chambre avec à peu près on va dire 3
à 4 accueillants familiaux qui seront
formés par le département pour s'occuper
donc de 12 à 2 10 à 12 personnes et
conseillers départementaux ont donc voté
de nouveau dispositif afin de
revaloriser les terres en friche et de
favoriser l'installation de jeunes
agriculteurs
un propriétaire en exploitant qui
souhaite vendre son terrain à un
agriculteur à un jeune agriculteur c'est
dû lui proposer une accompagnement de
l'ordre de 3000 euros l'état avec un
plafonnement à 20 mille euros est
également s'il souhaite mettre son
terrain à disposition à travers un bail
à ferme ça serait de lui accorder une
aide à 1500 euros
nous avons décidé d'accompagner le jeune
art et culture lorsqu'il fait
l'acquisition d'un foncier son outil de
travail
on va lui payer ses frais de notaire à
100% parmi les autres dossiers présentés
ce jour la mise en place du programme
départemental d'insertion 2016 2018 avec
une innovation la bourse d'emploi
destiné à tous ceux qui sont les plus
éloignés de l'emploi que nous mettons en
oeuvre avec les anpe pôle emploi
pourquoi pas ce que nous allons essayer
de leur offrir un travail partenarial
les meilleurs postes qui correspondent à
leur profil
et puis aussi un plan ambitieux pour
avoir un guichet unique pour pour ce
jeune ou ceux moins jeunes en demande
d'associations air référent unique pour
qu'ils n'aillent pas frapper à toutes
les portes des dossiers qui ont été
votées à l'unanimité par l'assemblée
départementale
la toute première mairie social ouvre
ses portes dans le domaine de la vanille
à s'attendre et sur ce même site et
regrouper l'ensemble des services d'aidé
à la personne
un guichet de la caisse d'allocations
familiales la maison départementale et
prochainement une antenne de la sécurité
sociale est une première à l'échelle de
l'île que cette mairie sociale qui
consiste à mettre en commun à travailler
ensemble à mutualiser les moyens et le
département est pleinement par titre
provenant de cette mairie social puisque
nous allons signer une convention entre
le département las le ccas
aujourd'hui de façon à ce que le
département met à disposition le son
local où les agents du ccas pourront
venir travailler avec les agents du
département pour accompagner les publics
en difficulté
je travaille en partenariat avec la caf
la cgss mon rôle est de d'accompagner
les gens dans leurs démarches en ligne
et de les rassurer le public pourra
également accéder à une plate forme
informatique ainsi qu'à des bornes
interactives de la caf et de la cgss
département et l'association jardins
créoles lance une opération de
valorisation de la rose de bourbon elle
s'était close pour la première fois dans
un parterre de nos jardins créoles et
porte le nom scientifique de rosa
bourgogne anna ou plus communément rose
bourbon un des parents c'est une robe de
chine
d'accord qui s'appelle haute bruche et
une autre c'est une rose de damas rosa
damascena florence alors le rossini la
propre caractère
remontant remonta c'est à dire que la
roselle refleurit tout le temps
tandis que les réussites damas ils ont
affronté un autre caractère c'est le
quartier le parfum notamment quand nous
faisons un appel à la population par
notre page facebook et par notre gaza
pour voir qui auraient encore d'un des
vieilles cours si rosiers anciens
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le département a
toute sa place dont le conservatoire
botanique au mascara de pouvoir remettre
en place un carré de la rose de bobo
avec toutes ces variétés
à saint-leu s'est déroulée la première
représentation publique de notre vie nos
vives un spectacle du groupe les
flamboyants composé de personnes en
situation de handicap
une action organisée avec l'équipe
socio-éducatif du département les
personnes fréquentent des ateliers à la
fréquence et deux fois par mois
donc tous les quinze jours où il ya on
se réunit dans une salle laval c'est
l'expression corporelle et de là est
venue l'idée de monter cette pièce que
j'ai fait c'est d'aider des blocages de
la timidité déjà un d'être bien avec
soi-même s'aimer soi pour se faire aimer
par les autres l'objectif de ce moment
et c'est de valoriser la personne à
travers un support telles que le théâtre
est donc je pense qu'il se sent en
sortie je pense bien
la septième édition du concours slam et
danses urbaines un lieu à l'occasion de
la fête de la musique le 21 juin au
théâtre de champ fleuri
la tâche du jury a été rude
issu du monde professionnel ou encore du
conseil départemental des jeunes
ces derniers ont eu beaucoup de mal à
départager les collèges
je pense que c'est vraiment une grosse
réussite par rapport à ce qu'on
attendait c'est exactement ce qu'ont
pensé les jeunes étaient vraiment
investi et là on a vu du slam et des
danses comme comme on le souhaitait les
professionnels étaient étaient ravis
cette année on a changé en tout petit
peu on a fait tous les prestations plus
tôt le matin le cours le matin et la
délibération de l'animation après midi
dans la catégorie slam les trois
premiers prix ont été attribués au
collège pointe des châteaux collège les
masques à rennes et le collège plateau
caillou le coup de coeur du jury a été
attribué au collège de la ravine des
cabris dans la catégorie danse urbaine
c'est le collège jean le toullec qui
remporte le concours ou deuxième prix
est attribué au collège dimitile c'est
le collège teixeira da mota qui décroche
la troisième place